what are your superpowers again i'm rich
[Music]
it's the one and only damn this snyder
cut is fire
hey everyone if you're like me and was
underwhelmed by 2017's justice league
and then found out they were gonna pump
it with millions of dollars more for a
director's cut you were probably like
some men just want to watch the world
burn but to my surprise i didn't think
zack snyder's justice league was better
i thought it was way better so in this
video we're going to take a look at some
of the biggest differences between
2017's justice league and 2021's
zack snyder's justice league what they
kept left out
changed or rearranged so make sure to
like and subscribe or the ghost of joss
whedon's career will come after you
i mean right off the bat and yes the
batman puns will get worse as the video
goes along
you'll notice the change in aspect ratio
long story short zack fell in love with
this vertical framing while shooting the
imax scenes in batman v
superman and decided to use it for all
of justice league
remember that really weird superman
mustache they had to pay thousands of
dollars to remove and it still looked
pretty shitty
that whole scene which opens wednes
justice league has been completely
removed in fact almost the entire
introduction has changed
zak starts right where batman v superman
left off with the death of superman
going even further by showing how his
death triggered the mother stones to go
ape [ __ ]
resulting in the arrival of steppenwolf
mira in the atlanteans along with lex
luthor and the amazonians all can sense
superman's scream
something that's not seen in the 2017
cut while the 2017 version
tells us that superman is dead like the
newspaper headline here or the cut
batman and robbers scene
it's because they know he's dead right
the 2021 version
shows us that he's dead with way more
time given to the characters
processing his death especially lois
which we'll get to in a bit
the 2017 version has a gossip rag asking
if superman bowie and prince return to
their planet and an article that reads
supergerm could end humanity pretty glad
they cut that one out of the new version
there's also this scene where a woman in
a hijab is accosted by some thugs which
i
assume is whedon's way to show that
crime is on the rise without superman
around
in snyder's justice league you'll notice
no screenplay credit is given to joss
whedon
who took over directing in 2017 after
snyder left to deal with the death of
his daughter autumn who
he dedicated the film to snyder's
justice league is split up into six
parts if you don't count the prologue
and epilogue separated by
title cards number one being don't count
on it batman
zack opts to start his story with batman
tracking down
aquaman while the weed cut starts with
diana and the bank heist it's during
this action scene we can see some of the
more
subtle differences between the cuts
whedon's color correction is more
vibrant while snyder's is more subdued
snyder gives us more exposition of why
these guys are here and even the music
is different check out the two versions
here and how snyder opts for a more
amazonian and exotic feel when
introducing diana
[Music]
the snyder cut is filled with different
music choices i won't get into all of
them but i'll point out some of my
favorites along the way
whedon's version also entirely cut out
the moment diana has with a young girl
and tells her she can be anything she
wants to be i mean i never imagine the
guy who's alleged to treat women
terribly on set to take out that scene
and not so subtle is how this scene ends
in both versions
in whedon's the camera basically fades
to white as she's about to kill the
baddie while snyder goes
all out with a huge ass explosion one of
the things i found weird about the
2017 version was why bruce wayne didn't
take a chopper or his own personal plane
to the secluded village he'll search for
aquaman in the snyder cut this is
addressed with some exposition
explaining that
storms have kept much of the area
inaccessible the 2017 version also
doesn't show us that bruce wayne speaks
fluent icelandic
i'm pretty sure that's what they're
speaking but let me know if i'm wrong
plus there's this whole weird cave
drawing of the boxes which
doesn't need to really be explained in
the snyder cut at least not yet
as they'll be fully fleshed out in the
story later on as aquaman leaves bruce
the 2017 version shows him speeding away
like a torpedo where in the snyder cut
he kinda just
mysteriously vanishes and the villagers
even come around and sing a song adding
to the lore that they treat him like
some sort of god
the snyder cut has an extra scene where
bruce arrives back from the village to
chat with alfred who gives him the idea
that maybe he shouldn't be the one to be
doing all the recruiting
maybe a man who broods in a cave for a
living isn't cut out to be a recruiter
perhaps the second most fleshed out
storyline in the snyder cut aside from
cyborgs is lois lanes
here we see her picking up a coffee for
a security guard who keeps watch over
the memorial
and we learn she visits it every day you
don't miss a day do you the whole lowest
grieving superman storyline is
pretty much non-existent in the 2017
version we even get a security bank of
manhattan seeks new architect
newspaper heading from the daily planet
which sets up bruce wayne's later
acquisition of a bank which he'll use to
buy back superman's childhood home
cut from the snyder version is batman
discussing with alfred what those boxes
could possibly be
and that scene with the flash where he
puts permanent marker all over a dude's
face this is substituted with a
completely new flash introduction scene
which includes hot dogs so you'll want
to stick around for that
steppenwolf's retrieval of the first box
signals a big difference between the two
versions
not only is steppenwolf's armor
different but the fight scene varies in
some pretty drastic ways
in both versions queen hippolyta
retrieves the box but in this snyder cut
we see her stop for a moment to help a
fellow amazonian
who says to run with the cube and honor
their deaths by sealing the gates
hippolyta even goes back to help another
amazonian
risking her life doing so but where
things get drastically different is
after hippolyta escapes
in the 2017 version steppenwolf cuts his
way through the stronghold
and continues his chase while in the
snyder cut the entire stronghold crashes
into the sea
steppenwolf and his parademons along
with it only to emerge later from the
depths
also the snyder cut has steppenwolf
completely throwing a horse and
being attacked by a dozen arrows which
he easily shrugs off with his
new armor i guess this is also a good
time to mention that the snyder cut has
an r rating
while justice league is pg-13 and as
we'll see later snyder's is
more violent when one of the amazons
attaches a rope to an
arrow the snyder cut has her eyes all
going starlight from the boys
while the 2017 version has no such
effect with one of the boxes now in his
possession the snyder cut varies wildly
from the 2017 version and how
steppenwolf is portrayed
his motivations in the snyder cut are
much more clear
and we actually see who he's reporting
to and why he's doing what he's doing
it's also explained early on on why he
chooses this abandoned type of chernobyl
town rather than
three quarters of the way through in
justice league and snyder
thank god got rid of that random family
storyline which influenced the plot in
no way
i will give it to the snyder cut for
those awesome product placements gotta
pay for those vfx reshoots somehow
the largest storyline to change is
arguably victor stones aka cyborg who in
the 2017 movie spends half of it in the
shadows brooding in the snyder cut we
get to see his backstory and how his
dad's use of the box brought him back to
life
and ties into the main storyline the
2017 version has almost
no emotional arc for cyborg with the
whole tape recorder speech his father
silas gives him
non-existent in it speaking of silas
there's his work at star labs along with
his partner ryan choi who isn't even in
the 2017 version
in the snyder cut he ends up becoming
the director of nanotechnology at star
labs after silas's death
a death that doesn't occur in whedon's
version in the snyder cut we have a far
simpler setup for how the justice league
finds steppenwolf's location in the
final act
silas learns that he can heat up alien
hardware to become the hottest thing on
the planet which is what he does to the
box so the justice league can trace its
heat signature
talk about hot boxing silas gives up his
life so that the justice league can
track steppenwolf's location this is way
more emotional than the 2017 version
which just says cyborg track it down
since the three boxes give off energy in
the snyder cut diana investigates the
location of the arrow her mother queen
hippolyta shot from theramisia using it
she finds a hidden tomb depicting the
great battle thousands of years ago
between darkseid and the old heroes a
battle in the 2017 version which does
happen but the villain is replaced with
steppenwolf and we'll get to more about
that
in a bit aquaman's decision to join the
justice league is more fleshed out in
the snyder cut as well
with full on scenes with volkow not
present in the 2017 version
who warns aquaman of the impending doom
even asking him to take
his mother's trident which he does not
aquaman will later use his mother's
trident making the scene where we first
see him use it and hold back the water
far more emotional he is simultaneously
joining the league while embracing his
mother who he previously disowned
there's also way more slo-mo
shirtless jason momoa wave crashing
shots and a new song to go with it and
snyder did away with this weird shot of
green algae from the 2017 version after
he saved the fisherman from the storm
this is supposed to be
parademon blood but a lot of people
including myself were initially confused
while watching the original one of the
other big differences in the snyder cut
is the addition of ares played by david
thulis who you may remember from wonder
woman he's actually the one who gives
darkseid his injury forcing him to
retreat and this injury is
super bloody in comparison to the 2017
version
yet another reason why it's rated r this
snyder cut also gives us
extended scenes of what happened to the
boxes after they were collected by the
three races and later on we'll even see
how the box that was held by man
was found by the nazis in a church in
france during world war ii
picked up by the allies and how it
eventually made its way to silas
perhaps one of the biggest deleted
scenes to be included is the
introduction of the flash in the
snydercut whereas in the
2017 version the first real scene we see
him in is him visiting his dad in prison
the snyder introduction sets up
a lot for this character showing us how
he's struggling to find a job
and anti-social literally running away
after saving a girl he clearly has his
eyes on in the wheaton version
steppenwolf moves straight on to
atlantis for the second box but the
snyder cut sees him interrogating some
atlanteans to learn of its location he
even uses this spider thing to read
people's minds later using it on silas
which the 2017 version
doesn't have in between these scenes the
snyder cut is littered with shots
depicting lois's grief as she deals with
superman's death like how she goes
through his things or lays awake at
night knowing he's not next to her
let's not forget the addition of a
pregnancy test in lois's bedside drawer
where they could go anywhere with this
this culminates in an emotional heart to
heart with martha kent where martha says
she needs to let go
compare this to the scene in whedon's
cut where they talk more about martha
losing her house than the death of the
man who connects them so dearly
of course the snyder cut has this added
twist where the martian mantunger takes
the form of martha
he seems to be orchestrating something
far bigger and we'll see him
introduce himself to batman in the
epilogue he's not seen in the 2017
version we also get a lengthier cyborg
origin story where we see the crash that
killed his mother and how his father put
him back together we also get an idea of
just how powerful cyborg is
his father telling him he could send out
all the world's nuclear weapons with
just a thought what do we get in the
weed cut flying a foot off the ground in
the apartment in the snyder cut this
happens on the roof and cyborg is given
way more thrusters plus these robotic
arm type things
not present in the 2017 version the
snydercut also gives us a glimpse at
cyborg's humanity like how he gives a
poor woman a hundred thousand dollars a
woman whose apartment was foreclosed by
gotham bank after finding out diana is
watching him the way he gets her
attention is different in both versions
in 2017 he conversates with her
over the computer in the batcave while
the snyder cut has him hacking the same
computer but with the message
meet here now the snyder cut also does a
better job at tracking where the box of
man
is seeing it at cyborg's apartment then
him burying it at his mother's grave
and later bringing it to the justice
league to resurrect superman in the weed
cut he just kind of arrives and is like
hey here it is
next up is the battle between meera and
steppenwolf at the atlantean stronghold
the snyder cut is far
lengthier with a major focus on mira
this is contrasted with the whedon cut
where most of the fighting is done
between
aquaman and steppenwolf and we don't get
this cool bit of exposition
where steppenwolf has mira pinned
against the wall or mira using this
power to suck
blood out of his face yeah the snyder
cut is way bloodier
now i gotta play this for you guys check
out the difference in the two cuts with
the music played when the justice league
arrives to save silas
boring
one left me like a limp noodle and the
other i was like hell yeah baby let's go
there are some other big differences how
this whole rescue operation goes namely
surrounding the flash in the wean
version he has this long speech with
batman about how he's never fought
before so he's relegated to saving the
hostages
this is removed in the snyder cut and he
kind of leads the hostages by themselves
instead of manually picking them up one
by one
plus there's a scene where he saves them
all from flying debris and thank god
they got rid of this totally unnecessary
scene where the flash lands on wonder
woman and it looks like he's humping her
directed by joss whedon the ween cut
also does away with any of the emotion
that comes with cyborg saving his father
whereas in the snyder cut we get
i wasn't sure he'd come you're my father
steppenwolf ends up escaping and
contacting darkseid where he tells him
that earth is where the anti-life
equation is located carved into the very
surface of the world
this equation as he calls it is the
ultimate weapon for controlling all
life throughout the multiverse this is
not in the 2017 version with the justice
league in possession of the third box we
get more backstory on what
exactly it is silas called it a change
machine as it can reinstate particles
they use the analogy of a house burning
down the house doesn't disappear its
particles just turn into something else
like ash and smoke
by this logic the change machine can be
used to bring superman back in the
wheaton cut they're more like hey we can
use this to jumpstart superman and away
they go
minor difference but when the flash
arrives to bruce wayne's bat cave he
flashes around to check it like a giddy
school boy which doesn't happen in the
snyder cut the gravedigging scene here
is
also extended in whedon's cut we never
get to see the interaction between
aquaman and diana here in fact they're
never even shown i found this
interaction between the two
a lot more genuine than the weiner
version where aquaman accidentally sits
on the lasso of truth and professes how
he thinks wonder woman is
cute you're gorgeous the decision to use
the box is questioned in the snyder cut
by alfred who is concerned its power
could have terrible consequences
if you start playing with this little
box of
tricks i mean it could be the end of
everything in the weed cut
this is brought up by diana technology
is like any other power without reason
without heart it destroys us
so the team has to bring superman's
corpse to the kryptonian ship at star
labs in the weed cut they kind of just
walk in there's hardly any security
except for the guy at the front gate and
they go about their business
in the snyder cut it's a whole big deal
they have to create a diversion and get
everyone who's working there out by
creating an alarm we also get a way more
in-depth view of what's in the
kryptonian ship like these different
superman suits and even a dead body
superman's resurrection in snyder's
version is intercut with shots of lois
visiting his memorial for the last time
bringing back that emotional weight to
the scene and setting up how she'll
bring him back to reality the plan to
jumpstart superman is the same in both
versions but just before barry is about
to use his electrical charge
cyborg is bombarded with images of the
future now i won't get into
too much details of what these images
mean but it's clear snyder is setting up
huge things for the dc universe we see
dead diana
dead aquaman who's wearing the king's
crown superman hovering over a dead body
dark side consoling superman and
superman holding batman's cow
it really sets up that superman could
actually be turning evil for good while
the justice league battles superman in
the wean version steppenwolf
comes in and joins the cube and just
takes off as mentioned before this
snyder cut sees him taking it from silas
superman goes off with lois and we get a
more fleshed out version of this reunion
and this magical line
the man's been dead for days one of the
big differences between the two versions
is
knowing superman will come and help the
justice league in the 2017 version it's
a surprise when he arrives to take on
steppenwolf but the snyder cut we know
he's eventually going to come
they wanted me back for a reason
i need to find out why then we get this
great scene where he gets into a new
dark suit as the voices of his real dad
jorel and his adopted dad jonathan kent
give voice over on how he can be a force
for good there's also this scene in the
weeden cut where diana pops a bruised
bruce wayne's shoulder back into place
and we find out it was bruce's idea to
bring in lois to turn
superman not at all what happens in the
snyder cut in deciding what to do next
the snyder cut also took out the scene
where aquaman gets really upset at
cyborg for his malfunction which set off
superman the team sets out with a plan
which is a lot different than whedon's
version here batman will destroy the
dome while the flash creates a band of
energy around the city while cyborg
attempts to desynchronize the cubes
this city itself is also devoid of
citizens while in the weeden cut you'd
get this weird hodgepodge of some shots
having no people at all
while others you'll see them screaming
for their lives the background sky is
totally different too whedon opting to
keep it orangy red while snyder keeps it
night superman even visits alfred in the
snyder cut
likely to find out where the team is
again not in the weeden cut and with
superman's arrival these two versions
differ extremely in the weed cut
superman blows cold air on steppenwolf's
axe and diana breaks it
the cubes are pulled apart and
steppenwolf is defeated there's also
this mini side story where the flash and
superman save the civilians this is all
thrown in the garbage by snyder who
gives us something far more thrilling
while setting up big things for the dcu
the snyder version sees superman beating
the crap out of steppenwolf even ripping
off his horn
but the justice league ultimately fails
and barry who was shot and couldn't pull
off the energy blast has to do something
he's
not supposed to do go faster than the
speed of light and move
back time we see as he moves so fast the
particles start to reform and when he
touches barry
well he's given a weird post-apocalyptic
family welcome
who want him to stay with him forever he
refuses and were transported back a few
moments before the blast that would kill
everyone allowing the entire team to
take a stab at steppenwolf
throwing him back through the portal to
darkseid's homeworld something this
snyder cut made me feel at the end was
that they were finally a team while
simultaneously setting up a conflict for
a sequel darkseid coming to earth to
take the anti-life equation with his
armada snyder's epilogue and post-credit
scenes are more fleshed out as well
in the 2017 version we see how cyborg is
good with his dad now even though little
time was spent on that
aquaman goes back to the water flash
runs around town wonder woman goes back
to stopping criminals and superman
reveals his traditional
colored s the wing cut also has that lex
luthor post credit scene both at the
asylum and
on his yawn the yacht version here
however has lex luthor telling deadshot
to put it plainly
shouldn't we have a league of our own
while in the snyder cut he says this
if you want the batman here is something
that
can help you his name is bruce wayne
this is great for the snyder version
since in that post-apocalyptic scene we
see deadshot has teamed up with batman
the snyder version also does away with
this superman in flash
racing scene in snyder's epilogue we see
cyborg in front of the grave of his
parents
batman catching up with some bad guys a
superman's grey s
and arguably the most talked about
change from the 2017 version
this scene involving batman and the
joker in a post-apocalyptic world i
won't get into too much of analysis of
the scene
that's for a different video but we
learned lots of cool things like how
dark side has taken over
something bad has happened to aquaman
lois and harley quinn are dead
alternate timelines and the arrival of
superman who looks like he wants to kick
the crap out of all of them so those are
some of my
favorite differences between whedon and
snyder's justice leagues what did you
think of the snyder cut and which
differences were your favorite that i
didn't include i want to hear them in
the comments below thanks for watching
everyone make sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on twitter and instagram
think story yt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much